do you think there's a story structure
that professionals use I think it's
different for everybody I don't think
there's one story structure that fits
everything a lot of people talk about
three-act structure and I kind of dog on
it a little bit because I think it
really oversimplifies everything and
there are some books that I won't name
that say that you need to have this
happen on this page and it's very strict
I think that just as long as you have a
main character that you for some reason
really care about and there's conflict
present and that conflict escalates and
keeps on escalating and you're still
engaged as an audience member that's
what people that's what the professional
writers you know use but it's in terms
of like a one structure I don't really
believe there is only one out there I
know when just watching back to the
future and doing a script analysis with
you you know different beats weren't
didn't seem like they were being met
exactly when some of these you know
story structure experts say they should
but you know it still works so I was
just wondering what your thoughts are
yeah I mean whatever really helps you as
a writer I mean if it does help you I
mean I know back to the future really
you know it does fit into that three-act
structure but I was just you know I
would just warn against some people you
know like you know some writers think
that it's like screenwriting religion
and I would just say that you know there
are plenty of films that don't fit 3x
structure
you